how are you Kevin I bought your your in
your intro my apologies
no Ritchie Ritchie I was one of the
worst quarterbacks in history in high
school University High School in Los
Angeles yeah thanks for covering for me
what oh I'm sorry I saw your buddy Chris
roses name next to yours here for
intentional talk made me think of the
NFI because I see him every day
every Sunday living and dying in the
front row of our screening room with the
Cleveland Browns so I see him every
single week so what did you what did you
think of the Red Sox come back when
yesterday Kevin is that is that a
bellwether for their chances heading
into Houston in your mind yeah it was a
big it was a big w for them they're
facing a really good ballclub the
Houston Astros and that's obvious but I
think the Red Sox are a really good
ballclub that probably came in not
getting the respect maybe deserved after
winning the most games you know in the
game I think they 108 and when you're
talking about Chris Sale the first game
doesn't look a hundred percent I think
for them to win the World Series I said
it before the series he needs to be a
hundred percent but David Price did
enough last night you know had a couple
scenes not go his way but was able to
get four two-thirds and the Red Sox
Jackie Bradley you guys played that
great at-bat and you know they're a good
ballclub it's it's gonna be a great
series I think before the series started
we all thought maybe it's going seven
and it'll be a dogfight
yeah sale doesn't look right to me Kevin
I think you're kind of hitting that
right on the head he does not look a
hundred percent at all to me what do you
think's wrong I don't know good shoulder
I don't know if it's dead arm I don't
know what it is I mean you look at Chris
Sale he loves the pitch right he's a
skinny tall wiry cat that that basically
when he's on he's on stuff 99 98 97
nasty wipeout slider you're not seeing
that going into the postseason only
through 79 you know since July we've
seen him go on deal a few different
times with shoulder and stuff and they
come back say was mechanical I thought
maybe he was playing the best possum in
history you know going in to the last
series I'm like if he comes out throw 99
this would be the greatest thing I've
ever seen but he could still win he
can still compete but he's not right you
know and I don't know exactly what it is
he's not right because the radar gun
shows that hm and then now here comes
Ivaldi who is just Heathrow there's no
question about his arm and his his
childhood idol is gonna be sitting
behind home plate in the form of Nolan
Ryan that is just gonna be lit and then
it's gonna be Keiko obviously for
Houston how do you see the next few days
playing out in Houston for this LCS
Kevin Millar well the good news is I
think the stadiums are about the same
they're both hitters ballpark right
green monsters 311 gotten over there in
Houston you got 300 left short porch in
right field in Houston I think that
evolve II if he throws the way he threw
against the Yankee's we were looking at
a hundred and 101 miles an hour with a
nasty slider stuff wives can match up
with anybody I think Red Sox win that
game Kaiko can be very good at home
though working that ball down below the
knees and soft get hitters to try to
pull and launch a lot of ground balls so
he doesn't have room to miss he ball
Deacon missed because with the hundred
you can miss down the middle and you can
miss up I don't think that psycho has
the ability or has the stuff wife to
miss male the plate cannot get hurt by
the Red Sox Kevin Millar here on the
Rich Eisen show and then in the NLCS you
know
Miley just he had it and III guess we're
in the day and age where you're just not
gonna allow a pitcher to throw against a
line of third time through Kevin the
Brewers took them out and obviously this
might be 20/20 hindsight but the Dodgers
are now even because of it I think I
mean are we are we in the day and age
where it's either Verlander or nobody
else gets to go through a lineup three
times over because of the metrics and
the way things get managed anymore I
don't I don't know where we at to be out
here Richie I starting to absolutely
drive me up a wall and and you know my
last year was in 2009 with the Blue Jays
and then got released in 2010 so I've
been removed from this game about eight
years as an active player it's truly
amazing in all of sports we
too much information you know in all of
sports and that's okay give me
information but let's not forget about
the eye test our eyeballs are the iPad
watch the game
watch the it batch watch the exit
velocity we can use that translation the
spin rate whose which is brought in
every inning and here's this spin rate
that's all cute and fine and dandy rich
but at the end of the day your eyeballs
control this game and and I think the
gut feeling we're losing that the true
ace that's allowed to get the ball and
go we're losing we're losing a lot of
stuff in this game
and it's starting to you know the David
Freese you'd give an example with David
Freese he hit third started for your Los
Angeles Dodgers in Game two and got two
innings and was taken out of the game
because a lefty can tie right he came in
and so max monkey then is implemented in
the game and now the Dodgers bench went
out by whatever it was seventh inning
seventh inning seventh inning they were
done right Homer there the Dodgers are
in a big-time trouble they're gonna
they're down you know too old so you can
look at it any other way or how you want
to look at it I don't know if it's great
for baseball right now I mean you know
we got starters we got you've got
bullpen starters you got metrics and
pinch hitters and taken out like where
are we at if our eyeballs are telling us
something that's fine
but because it's almost like we're
robotic and about a third turnaround we
can't face the third guy it happened
last year Rich Hill will take it out of
the game when it's rain in the World
Series hopeful get seven strikeouts game
each other and Brandon Morrow and it
cost the Dodgers that situation I think
at the end of the day and this is a Dave
Roberts this is a Craig Counsell this is
the situation that's around you know
there's 15 guys in that table fourth
game everything's premeditated so they
answer that question yeah it's starting
to drive me nuts and it's you know I
love baseball I'm a fan of it but I I
think we're losing the gut feeling and
the eyeball test yeah I know cuz the
four managers that are in the dugout
pushing these buttons are all guys that
played with heart right that got through
got into the major leagues I mean
obviously AJ Hinch also played catcher
but these are guys that that that needed
that
sort of
human element to survive and succeed in
baseball and might have been metric out
right Kevin I mean that's nuts to me
when I look at it it's it's nuts it's
not rich it's not you one more calling
flags with it with the with the
linebacker or defensive end landing now
we have a body weight as you're taking
footballs and now you know because if
the launch factor and then the UCL as
ours and we have the war which is Wins
Above Replacement made-up stat so we
have all these made-up scenes I just
want you to understand when you take the
field in Major League Baseball it's nine
on nine and it's let's go win the inning
and then we're going to try to win this
game and then we're gonna try to
pinch-hit late in the game when they
have a specialist comes in you know back
in the old days in a specialist Babe
Ruth didn't face specialist so
specialist lefty on lefty got it we're
gonna pinch-hit the righty here comes
rich eyes and have the dugout in a sandy
we're down by one those are moves that's
the cat mouse game move you're telling
me the third inning David Freese can't
face a right-hander by the way and you
would rather have max Muncey face Josh
hater in the seventh inning and you're
making that move in the third that's
what you're saying so why not just start
max Muncie and staying safe David Freese
for Jeffress and I'm just use an example
yep this is what we're dealing with now
yeah and I always say it's bad for
baseball I I just don't know if I'm just
love the sports so much cuz I'm I'm
riveted still you know what I mean like
some of this action
has been really intense but I I feel it
I feel what your sand Kevin you know I
mean Ron darling said during the ALCL
d/s at one point that the day and age of
pitchers being allowed to work their way
through trouble in the fourth or fifth
inning of games in October are over
there over by the way going forward how
do you pay a starter these days where's
the max max Scherzer's right Clayton
Kershaw's Justin whatever I'm just you
know those are elite but how do you how
can you now go sign it if you have a 22
year old stud that's coming up in the
big leagues how is he gonna make money
as a starting pitcher I'm just I'm just
askin because he's not allowed to go
more than 80 pitch
maybe you've got a standing ovation from
Severino who walked off and with four
eens in Yankee Stadium I was at the game
the wild card game for any standing
ovation David Price went for 2/3 yes pay
get his job in this day and age you know
and so I don't know maybe it's good
baseball but I don't I don't I don't
want to blip be like the old school oh
my god when I played that's not it it's
just a few scenes artwork butts going
too far I think you know we're gonna
pretty much have robots run around and
where's the human factor I guess well
Kevin Millar here on the Rich Eisen show
a few more minutes
yeah I don't want to get us in trouble
with Major League Baseball but if we
have just gotten ourselves in trouble
with baseball saying this we know he can
take we know we know who can take a
bullet for us and it's Joe West Kevin
because man he took that he took that
vasquez throw down a second right off
the shot I mean he may even move he
didn't even try to move you just took it
yeah yeah right what are the players say
when Joe West takes one what goes on in
the club what goes on the dugouts when
we see something like that happen Kevin
hey probably go back to a bad car
squeeze strike zone or something laughs
we got it no I didn't hurt it Robert Joe
Joe Joe got play the old cowboy role you
know I'm playing out CDs behind the
behind the thing but that was it that
was a pickup play I mean a line drive
that thing was going in a right field
it's held right I know Mandy hardly even
moved is this music any good I haven't
even heard it you ever heard Joe West
music Kevin is it gone no no I got I'll
do bench press to Godsmack and Metallica
throwing some Kenny Chesney sitting on
depend upon the balcony but I've been
put in a Jowett CD in a while okay me
journey Asia all right so I had a
pressure for it which I'm about to who
wins these next few games and makes the
World Series Kevin your best guess right
now
all right well as they and you know this
when we work the sport you're really
important on a long travel theme because
we're going to the show every single day
in well three so I don't want to see the
Red Sox and Dodgers you got six hours
back-and-forth Ricky okay
okay I'm a father of four and I want to
be home for Halloween I need six games
and under okay I'm gonna tell you right
now I think it's it's it's Red Sox
Dodgers World Series okay and who is
your your costume hood and what's your
costume of choice for Halloween right
now Kevin what are you I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be I looked it up I'm trying we're
gonna be a family of Americans and like
American flags Oh am I on my daughter
might be a star okay
they're great costumes we're gonna be a
red white and blue I'm gonna all have to
give out candy for a half an hour and
then all the wife give out candy for
half an hour and the dad will hit the
flares with the trailer and the hey and
then we're gonna go throughout the
neighborhood until all the chocolate
okay so what what are you giving out
what's the candy at the Millar house
when people come in and trick-or-treat
at the Millar house you know what's our
patch kids who doesn't love Reese's I
don't want to give out candy you're not
gonna eat you're gonna eat the candy
because like I'm gonna go with my
favorites which are sour pads and
Reese's and stuff like that but I don't
like when you get like Necco you know
you know you know somehow there's like a
thing that goes my couch gets deep down
because that could survive a nuclear
holocaust Kevin those things could be 90
years old that could be from that could
be from the New Deal era and it still
tastes fresh the neck goes you know I'll
be honest with you Kevin I'm not a sour
guy I'm pass on the sour patches yeah
hey I'm here Clay Buchholz what do you
like buckles with your favorite he loves
our to what do you like Ritchie I'm a
skittles guy Kevin skills jelly beans
any day to word hey power skills are all
sour I'm not a sour guy just not sour
I'm more sweet I got the sweet tooth
skittles and I'm on the low end of the
scale candy corn and I'm not afraid to
admit it Oh upsetting airheads by the
way candy corns their heads are
underrated that might be a package that
might give out through the merica spree
if you want to go old school spring
spray Kevin I got ya I got fake
[Laughter]
Kevin Love the chat
say hi to clay Buckholtz for us okay
well calls rich says hi hey Kevin I
don't wanna get you in trouble but I ask
you a question did you ever did you did
you have as a Red Sox fan a problem with
a-rod wearing a Red Sox jersey no I
loved it I loved Ortiz and his banter
and then when the Sox win and they beat
the Yankees all right now let's get your
Red Sox uni right yeah but a finally get
right yeah if I had to give you it's a
great skit great for TV but I tried to
give you ten cracks at a Yankee to put a
Red Sox fan Red Sox jersey on you
wouldn't choose a-rod come on right you
choose Jeter Rivera like wouldn't you
say if I gave you ten shots you might
not even get around a rod to put one
underneath Jeter Mariano the only thing
yeah they they got everything in life
except a nice hairline so I probably
choose those guys you know fam here they
look great it looked like you still
played but the hair is a little rough go
hang out we'll chat we'll check you out
an intentional talk as we do every day a
5:00 p.m. Eastern on MLB Network with
you and Chris Rose good chat with you as
always Kevin all right that's Kevin
Millar the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience